Namo dasa bhagavato harahato sama sambodasa Namo dasa bhagavato harahato sama sambodasa
Namo dasa bhagavato arahato sama sambuddhasa homage to the buddha the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one i've got my little microphone as usual so uh being spring or april anyway i thought we would uh have a go at joy
the first thing i did was to look up all the synonyms we have so the pleasure enjoyment happiness gladness delight thrill exaltation elation bliss ecstasy rapture and absorption that's not bad is it and it's all good see it's not as though the buddha asked us to be miserable all the time even though he
even though most of the teaching is about getting rid of suffering.
You know, he was asked, how does he feel when he teaches and somebody doesn't accept the teaching?
So he said he feels all right with it.
It's calmer.
But when somebody does accept his teaching, he feels happy, feels joyful.
Now, it's an interesting thing that all my teachers never introduced us into the practice of joy.
It's very strange, meta, meta all the time, compassion a little bit, but joy never.
And it always, I don't know why, well, I'm thinking that why they did it because of the problem of indulgence.
And I think that's what goes wrong, of course.
All these beautiful mental states to which we are heir of corrupt as soon as we try to hold on to them or want more of them.
So it's a case of recognizing that nothing is repeatable and that when it's gone, it's gone and there's no point in anchoring after it.
So that, for instance, if you take a morsel of food which you delight in, you know, once you've swallowed it and you've got the aftertaste gone, that's it, let go.
Now this fear, this fear of indulgence actually destroys joy.
And I noticed it in the monastic life more than in lay people.
So for instance,
At the monastery, Kandamoda, there would be obviously occasions when people would come with special foods to celebrate a birthday, a marriage, and so on and so forth.
And one of the things that is quite lovely is buffalo curd, miikiri.
And it was handed out, you see, and you put loads of sugar with it, or kittel juice, a bit like maple juice, you know, and it's wonderful.
And we're all eating it, you see, and there was a monk sat next to me who was the picture of the ascetic, you know, very gaunt, and his cheeks were like this, you know, and...
And I knew him, you know.
And as we got round, while we were eating, he was glaring, as it were, at this curd, you know.
And as we came to the finish, he sort of leant forward quite slowly, lifted it up slowly, and then basically shoveled it down his throat.
And I've always presumed he was just so afraid of indulgence.
So that's no good, is it?
There was another case, too.
There was my teacher, Sayadaw Ujanaka.
uh about i would say around about 10 years ago he taught at a place called beatenberg which is uh near it's in interlaken which is right you know those beautiful lakes in uh switzerland and from it on a beautiful day you can see these three great mountains the eiger the monk and the jungfrau anyway
uh during the retreat the weather was miserable rainy cloudy etc and one day it all opened up and it's a glorious sight the white peaks against this deep blue sky you know so everybody on the retreat went out onto the balcony and outside to have a look you see well he gave him hell didn't he he upset a lot of people he told them they were useless meditators
were just indulging and he's wasting his time and all sorts so uh i don't think he was invited again and i remember whenever i would say something like uh you know isn't that a beautiful flower he would say ah yes but it fades you know it fades it dies so a bit of a killjoy really but his intention of course was to awaken me to the problem of indulgence
And that seed of indulgence is always there, you know, right to the bitter end.
Mara is always right there, just waiting for the moment to creep up on us.
so uh it's a case of just recognizing these two things that uh if we if we begin to see what the what the consequences of indulgence are then we'll be we'll make ourselves afraid to enjoy something but actually if for instance you have a biscuit right and you finish a biscuit the last thing goes down flavor's gone and then you get this i think i'll have another one
So as soon as that comes, you know, well, that's greed, right?
So you have to sit there and wait for that to exhaust itself.
Now, once you've done that, you've exhausted the karmic consequence of the greed that arose while you were eating that biscuit.
I think it's as simple as that.
I know somebody who got into the habit of eating biscuits just before they went to bed.
And he was getting rather afraid of it.
So instead, he turned to music.
And now that's a skillful thing.
If you find that, you know, an indulgence feels a little bit overwhelming, then put your attention on some other joyful thing that you like to do.
So there we are.
There's the fear.
The fear of indulgence undermines, destroys enjoyment of joy.
And to...
to become indulgent with our joys, wanting more of this, more of the same.
It's just the old suffering.
So now the question is, why is it we remember mostly at the end of the day, the painful parts and hardly any of the joys, right?
Well, I suppose the reason is because painful things hurt.
But unfortunately, it does shadow out the joys of the day.
So we have to make a special effort to remember the joys of the day, right?
Instead of obsessing about our failures and our upsets, we can contemplate the successes and joys of the day.
Now, the interesting thing is, the more you make yourself aware of the joys of the day, the more you bend that way and the more you see what is actually undermining your joy.
And this, of course, creates even greater joy.
So we try to rid ourselves of behaviours which undermine our joy and over time our joy grows.
And of course, this is done with a certain affectionate awareness.
And this is towards ourselves, you know, being kind to ourselves, gentle to ourselves and seeking what lifts the heart.
Yeah, music, nature, friendship and so on.
Now, this word mudita, which is one of the four Brahma-viharas, remember, so love, compassion, joy, and peacefulness, equanimity, are the four great mental states.
These we can develop indefinitely.
And it's often translated as appreciative joy, reciprocal joy.
And what this does, of course, is it undermines envy and jealousy.
And I define those two as saying that envy is wanting what the other person has and jealousy is wanting what the other person has and hating them for having it in the first place.
Now, it's interesting in the East, you know, if you make a donation to a cause, if you make a donation to a, say, a monastery, all the names are posted up with exactly how much you gave.
You know, so it starts off with, I don't know, maybe a thousand pounds and it goes all the way down to, you know, a couple of shillings.
That's an old word, isn't it?
so if you if you and it's done because in the east it's understood that people will rejoice in the good karma that you have gained by your offering now when it came to bill gates giving his millions away i wonder what our response was you know well he got all that money he should be able to give something away you know the one percenters
Did we say, oh, good on Bill, you know, may he receive many blessings.
So he's got enough blessings.
So here we have that sort of reciprocal joy of actually being joyful in somebody else's successes and joys.
And I think it comes as a revelation that we can actually be more joyful for others than for ourselves.
And this is not strange, of course, to parents who rejoice in the successes of their offsprings.
know i remember once uh i must have been about maybe 12 years old because my sister's 11 years younger than me and i got back from school and i sat opposite my mother and she held uh maria you see and encouraged her to walk towards me and of course when she did i mean it was joy you know it was wonderful to see this little this little toddler trying to make his way
So this development of being joyful for other people in the joys of other people and the successes of other people is really heartlifting.
And joy is also a restorative.
Somebody's called it restorative joy.
So there you are down in the dumps, right?
And you think to yourself, well, how can I lift my heart?
How can I bring joy into my heart?
Whatever level, it doesn't always have to be amazing ecstatic joy.
It's just feeling happy, generally happy.
So that's when you meet up with a friend or you watch a good film and so on.
In the monastic life, of course, the daily routine tends to be the same.
I mean, even when there's a feast day, the only difference is you turn up for a better meal and then you go back and it's just the same.
So it can be very, you know, it can move you towards a sense of apathy, a sense of laziness and all that.
And it was then that I realized the amazing power of a long, mindful cup of tea.
No doubt about it.
So, I mean, if we just list all those things, you know, this is not an exhaustive list, but, you know, just the sensual joys that we get that lift the heart, relations of happiness, just the religious joys of, you know, feast days.
Now the ethical joys are really what the Buddha points to, right?
So as far as he's concerned, virtue goodness equals happiness.
And in chapter 20 of the Dhammapada, which is a lot of the verses are devoted to being happy.
This is what he says.
Oh, how happily we live without hate among those with hate, among people who hate we live without hate.
Oh, so how happily we live without misery among those in misery.
Among people in misery, we live without misery.
oh how happily we live without ambition among those with ambition among people with ambition we live without ambition now just a note on that ambition there's nothing wrong with us offering our talents for the benefit of the company um people etc etc but of course it becomes corrupt we start thinking about money and power
So the whole idea really, if we want to develop joy is to bend that way.
So here it is.
So what have we talked about?
We've talked about the enemies of joy.
We realize how corruptive indulgence is, how it becomes an obsession, how it's, what they call it, feeding the dragon.
And because of that, we can't allow ourselves to enjoy something.
And then of course, there's the indulgence itself, which becomes a trap in itself.
That's feeding the dragon.
And the way we do it is by becoming more aware of our daily joys and just bending life towards that way, just as we do with metta.
And then we have this reciprocal joy, you know, undermining envy and jealousy and really being happy for other people's happiness.
And finally to use joy to lift the heart when we feel a bit down in the dumps.
Yeah.
So here are some exercises.
You have to make a resolution, you see.
If at the end of today, you sit and you think now, you know, how happy was I today?
And all you can remember is the miseries.
Then you have to make a determination that tomorrow, you'll actually acknowledge when you're happy, any level of happiness, any level of joy.
It could just be contentment, right?
And just to acknowledge it.
And doing that, of course, you remember it by the end of the day.
The other thing you might try to do is to contemplate every evening for about a week, maybe five, 10 minutes, and just go back in your life and just think of all the joys you've had.
All the joys you've had.
And by the end of the week, you'll have a big smile on your face.
And the other thing is the practice of joy, which is like Metta.
So you go through all the categories, but the blessings are, may you be joyful, may you be ever more joyful.
Now those are the, shall we say, the ones that are regularly used.
I like to add, may you attain the sublime peace of nibbana.
Now the problem with nibbana is that there's no emotions in nibbana, right?
So it's not that sort of happiness.
In fact, that's what Sariputta said.
He says it's the very absence of emotions which is the bliss of nibbana.
That's a bit difficult for us, but at least we can, shall we say, make that intention because, you know, according to the Buddha, this is the highest of all happinesses.
So, may you be joyful, may you be ever more joyful,
May you attain the sublime peace of the abhorrent.
So I think peace rather than bliss.
I've sometimes used bliss.
You know, peace gives you, I think, a slightly better feel for it.
And as I say, at the end of this hour, that's what I'll be doing.
I'll be doing joyful meditation instead of metta.
Very good.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance, that I have not caused confusion, and that by your development of joy, you will be joyful sooner rather than later.